- He's one of the biggest
movie stars in Hollywood.
He has a net worth of 150 million dollars.
Oprah Winfrey said in all
of the years of her show,
he was one of their greatest teachers.
He's Jim Carrey
and here are is top ten rules for success.
- Who would have thought,
in all of the years of the Oprah show,
that Jim Carrey would be one
of our greatest teachers?
I think it's really a marvelous thing,
that visualization thing you did.
Do you all read about this or hear this?
That you use to go up on
Mulholland Drive and park.
- Yeah, every night.
- And park and visualize,
seeing yourself as...
- Yeah, I would visualize,
yeah I would visualize--
- This is when you were broke and poor.
- Right, having directors interested in me
and people that I respected saying,
"You know, I like your
work," or whatever that is
and I would visualize things coming to me
that I wanted or whatever.
- This was in like 1987, 85.
- Yeah, yeah.
- And didn't you--
- And I had nothing at that time.
So, it was like, it just
made me feel better.
It made me, at that time,
all it really was for me
was kind of making me feel better.
I would drive home and think,
"Well, I do have these things.
"They're out there.
"I just don't have a hold of them yet,
"but they're out there.'
- [Oprah] So didn't you
write yourself a check?
I heard that you did, is it true?
- Yeah, I wrote myself a
check for 10 million dollars
for acting services rendered
and I gave myself five
years, or three years maybe,
and I dated it Thanksgiving 1995
and I put it in my wallet
and I kept it there
and it deteriorated and
deteriorated and stuff.
But then, just before Thanksgiving 1995,
I found out that I was going
to make 10 million dollars on,
I think it was Dumb and Dumber.
And when I say life doesn't happen to you,
it happens for you, I really
don't know if that's true.
I'm just making a conscious choice
to perceive challenges
as something beneficial
so that I can deal with them
in the most productive way.
You'll come up with your own style.
That's part of the fun.
All my life I've really wanted to do this,
so it doesn't seem like
I've been in the business
for a short time.
It's all I've ever wanted to do.
It's all I've ever done.
Just this insane belief in my own ability
to manifest things, insane belief.
You know, that I think it's
ultimately complete sanity,
but I believe we're creators.
And I believe we create with every thought
and every word and
every moment is pregnant
with the next moment of your life.
You already know who you are
and that peace, that
peace that we're after,
lies somewhere beyond personality.
Your need for acceptance
can make you invisible in this world.
Don't let anything stand
in the way of the light
that shines through this form.
Risk being seen in all of your glory.
(applauding)
I have no education.
I had no high school diploma.
I didn't even have a GED.
I quit high school
halfway through grade 10.
I didn't have a lot of options.
I would be dishwasher or a waiter
or custodial work of some sort.
So I decided, I might as well
go and do something creative.
I decided to go to The Comedy Store,
Laugh Factory, and Improv,
you know, all of those clubs, every night
and make my 25 bucks a pop a set.
It was my version of being a waiter.
It was a compromise I decided to make.
Out of that came In Living Color
and out of that came touring
auditoriums, 5,000 seaters.
It was a really creative time.
I was able to prove
that I didn't have to be an impressionist,
that I had a personality of my own,
that however abrasive it
might be from time to time.
But long story short, all of
it came from that compromise,
from that deciding to do
what I didn't want to do.
The things you can't do
or the things you're not allowed to do,
like if the executives come
and say you can't do that,
whatever it is, it's too expensive.
You get angry, you get
out of your mind about it
because you've been
clinging to this concept
and this image that you have
of how it should be done.
And, invariably, most times
after that storm has passed
and you actually sit down and go,
"Okay, we can't do it that way.
"How can we do it?"
You end up with something even better
than what was there before.
And you go, "Oh, that's the universe.
"That's how it works."
Just like relationships, like everything.
The thing that is taken away,
if you're clinging to
it, you're trying to fix,
and you're trying to secure it,
make sure it doesn't go away.
You think your life will be destroyed,
everything will be ruined.
And it's just the universe going,
"No, I have something better
for you, just have faith."
Sometimes compromise is actually the way
to get to what you want.
You are ready and able to do
beautiful things in this world.
And after you walk
through those doors today,
you will only ever have
two choices, love or fear.
Choose love and don't ever let fear
turn you against your playful heart.
Total believer, yeah.
I believe in manifestation.
I believe in, you know,
putting a rocket of desire
out into the universe
and you get it when you believe it.
You get it when you believe you have it.
And that's they key, is like people still,
they sit around going,
"When's it going to come,
"when's it going to come,
when's it going to come,
"when's it going to come?"
And that's the wrong way.
You're facing the wrong way.
You're facing away from it.
You have to go, "It's here,
it's here, it's here."
It's our intention.
Our intention is everything.
Nothing happens on this planet without it.
Not one single thing
has ever been accomplished
without intention.
You can spend your whole
life imagining ghosts,
worrying about the pathway to the future,
but all there will ever be
is what's happening here
and the decisions we make in this moment,
which are based in either love or fear.
So many of us choose our path
out of fear disguised as practicality.
What we really want seems
impossibly out of reach
and ridiculous to expect.
So we never dare to ask
the universe for it.
I'm saying, I'm the proof
that you can ask the universe for it.
Please.
(applauding)
And if it doesn't happen
for you right away,
it's only because the universe is so busy
fulfilling my order.
(laughing)
My father could have
been a great comedian,
be he didn't believe that
that was possible for him.
And so he made a conservative choice.
Instead, he got a safe
job as an accountant.
And when I was 12 years old,
he was let go from that safe job
and our family had to do
whatever we could to survive.
I learned many great
lessons from my father.
Not the least of which was
that you can fail at what you don't want.
So you might as well take a
chance on doing what you love.
(applauding)
- Thank you so much for watching.
I made this video because
Daniel Grantham asked me to.
So if there's a famous entrepreneur
that you want me to profile,
leave a comment below,
let me know who it is and I
just might make a video on it.
Thank you for watching,
continue to believe,
and I'll see you soon.